vous avez souvent dit avoir fréquenté
beaucoup les boîtes échangistes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est bidon
[Musique]
est-ce que je peux me faire un petit
kiff way locales et c'est bien je peux
encore patrick harris j'en ai parlé
comme assez génial c'est génial j'adore
ce que d'amour et je les fais les marais
on y va vous avez tous une question il
faut répondre sembla vous êtes tous
préparent une question ici je sais même
pas de quoi vous avez parlé que vous
avez souvent dit avoir fréquenté
beaucoup les boîtes échangistes était la
réaction des gens quand ils vous
reconnaissez ces jeux de jeu
[Applaudissements]
les protections et malaxeurs je vais pas
te les imiter au hockey ce qu'on l'ait
bien non il n'y a pas de réaction
particulière
tu sais là dedans que tu connais
[Applaudissements]
d
mais ça me ferait chaud
[Musique]
ce qui m'amuse réa c'est le 14 novembre
à la prochaine c1 samedi et je voulais
leur faire donc le 14 ans de l'année
prochaine et en profiter pour qu'au
niveau national on décide de faire une
soirée là après la fête des mères la
fête la fête de la fête
c'est à dire que chacun se déguise chez
soi que vous fassiez la fiesta que cette
journée-là qui serait pour ce soit
toujours un samedi parce qu'autrement
dans la semaine ce serait difficile que
ce soit le deuxième samedi de novembre
en plus en pleine grisaille c'est en
plein automne juillet face une journée
déguisée
la caisse
[Applaudissements]
pas d'imagés on
[Musique]
on fait corps et